well it's been two decades since my next
two guests agreed to debate one other on
live television both noral finlin and
Alan dtz are Jewish but their
perspectives on the Israel Palestine
conflict couldn't be more different and
they both join me now the lawyer and
author of the war against the Jews Alan
dtz and Professor Norman finlin well
welcome to both of you um I feel a bit
like Kofi and an bringing you two
gentlemen back together uh but I'm glad
that you've both agreed and I hope we
can have a civilized debate we've had
some pretty uh ranker us debate week on
the program and I want to try and really
have a proper conversation about where
we are on this war and about this
Burning question I'll start with you
Anan DZ about what we're
seeing in Gaza now is to many people uh
now the very terrorism which Israel set
out to destroy what do you say to people
that think
that it is Terrorism it's terrorism by
Hamas taking human Shields putting
children in the way of Israel's
legitimate military concerns Hamas has a
strategy it's called the CNN strategy I
call it the dead baby strategy kill as
many Jews as possible provoke Israel
into doing what every democracy would do
responding then hide your tunnels and
your Fighters and your Rockets behind
civilians knowing that Israel no matter
how hard they try to avoid civilian
casualties and why would Israel ever
want to kill a civilian it's absurd it
hurts them tremendously but every time
Israel kills a civilian the world
condemns them the United Nations
condemns them and then that process
continues over and over and over again
the people who are being killed today
are being killed as a result of Hamas
actions Hamas started it Hamas uses
human Shields if Hamas lay down its arms
if it surrendered if it uh agreed to
give up control if it uh closed its
tunnels if it stopped stop this Rockets
uh then no civilians would be killed so
it's a terrible tragedy there's no good
solution there's no perfect solution if
Israel stops now Hamas continues to do
it over and over and over again if
Israel continues it gets condemned and
loses friends abroad and even risks
using the United States it's a terrible
dilemma for Israel all the
responsibility all the fault of Hamas
for starting this and let me just end
with one quote on the day after
literally the day after these horrible
tragedies with murders and rapes and
robberies this is what Mr finlin said it
warms every fiber of my soul every fiber
of my soul he called the people who
murdered these innocent Jews me many of
them peac Nicks he called them part of
the heroic resistance and he compared
them to the Jews who were fighting
against Nazis in the warsa ghetto it's
that kind of animosity toward isra
Israel before Israel fired a single shot
which makes it clear that no matter what
Israel does it's going to be condemned
by people like Norman finlin and by the
United Nations General Assembly I think
it was Abby Ean who once said if the
general assembly were asked to vote on
an Algerian resolution that the Earth is
flattened that Israel flattened it it
would win 128 to 32 with 65 extensions
and he would name each of the people so
the United Nations General Assembly
Rights Watch Doctors Without Borders
these are not objective assessments
Israel is in a very tough situation and
the future of civilization depends on
Israel being able to destroy Hamas and
avoiding repetition BR let me bring in
Professor Thinkin your response to
that well I won't address the question
of my remarks on October 7th because we
already went over that ground in the
previous program and so would be a waste
of your viewers time if I were to re
revisit that yeah so let me deal with
the sub yeah thank you so let's deal
with the substantive issue number one
what you seem to be describing as a new
development namely Israel's
indiscriminate assaults in Gaza that's
hardly a new development with all due
respect to you I I've lost the uh Israel
from is Israel from uh
literally day one set out as its goals
so if I can quote um first of all the
defense minister there will be no
electricity no food no water no fuel
everything is closed we are fighting
Human animals and we are acting
accordingly now that was not directed at
Hamas that was directed at the entire
population of Gaza I think your
listeners understand what is the
consequence of denying a civilian
population all water all food all Fuel
and all electricity it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure out that that
is a recipe for
genocide number two you quoted or you
had on Douglas Murray who made a
distinction between what he called the
deliberate targeting of civilians versus
the
indiscriminate targeting of
civilians not to want to sound
pedantic but Israel's leading Authority
on international law is a fellow named
yuram denstein who I'm sure sure Alan
dtz knows and Mr denstein or Dr denstein
he stated that there is no fundamental
difference under international law
between the deliberate targeting of
civilians and the
indiscriminate targeting of
civilians there is no substantive
difference therefore under international
law according to yuram denstein
Israel is
targeting the civilian population of
Gaza that's another indication from the
GetGo not from
yesterday not when not from when it was
revealed to President Biden but from the
GetGo Israel has been engaging in a
genocidal war in Gaza now the genocidal
War takes various forms again I'm going
to cite you old quotes so let's take
Gora Island who was the head of Israel's
National Security Council the equivalent
of our CIA and he said quote Israel
needs to create a humanitarian crisis in
Gaza Gaza will be become a place where
no human being can
exist now I'm not here to try to
persuade Mr dtz or Professor dtz I am
here to try to Enlighten your listeners
so I would like them to
cogitate to meditate over what does it
mean to say Gaza will become a place
where no human beings can exist Mr
Island the former head of the National
Security Council went on to
say severe epidemics in the south of the
Gaza Strip will bring Victory closer and
reduce casualties among IDF
soldiers and then there is Mr Netanyahu
the prime
Minister not on one
occasion
not from the spur of the moment but
twice in National
addresses in to the nation very
soberly Mr Netanyahu said remember what
amalec did to you this is a war between
the sons of Light and the sons of dark
Darkness now as Professor dwit surely
knows because he attended Hebrew
school actually he grew up just a few
blocks from me or I should say I grew up
a few blocks from him because he's older
he surely knows that in the midst of a
war in a country that is schooled in the
Bible that when you say your enemy is
amalec then you are calling for the
destruction the killing of every man
woman and child so with all due regard
to Mr dtz I have to say this issue of
human
shielding is totally beside the point
because it doesn't even come into play
in this particular situation the orders
from the GetGo denying food water
electricity and fuel to the entire
civilian
population the order from the GetGo to
turn Gaza into a place that is not able
to sustain human life the order from the
GetGo in this battle between the sons of
Light and the sons of Darkness okay I
repeat I do not believe it requires a
rocket scientist to figure out that from
day one which is to say two mons you
made the point Israel has been waging a
war of genocide in Gaza you've made the
point so much you've made the point come
back to Professor duritz uh here's the
problem it seems to me I've just
listened to Norman felstein at length uh
outlining that side of the argument it's
very hard when you look at what has
actually been happening in Gaza in the
last two weeks in particular to avoid a
conclusion that Israel doesn't really
seem to care if it levels Gaza to the
ground as long as it can get rid of
Hamas my issue with that is having
defended their moral right to defend
themselves as a country is I don't think
they're going to eliminate Hamas and
they're certainly not going to eliminate
the ideology and they're going to
basically end up with a Gaza that's
flattened 2 million people dis placed
where are they going to live who's going
to run Gaza how does this actually play
out other than catastrophically
badly it will play out catastrophically
badly because of what Hamas has done we
have to remember first of all you judge
people by their actions not by their
words the quotes from Professor denstein
who's been retired for probably 25 years
and Elon who's has nothing to do with
the Israeli government are individuals
denstein is 100% wrong I'll give you an
example is there no difference between
Nazis putting Jews deliberately six
million of them into gas Chambers and
and other means of death deliberately
targeting them and what the United
States did at Hiroshima Nagasaki they
may both be wrong but there's an
enormous difference between deliberately
targeting civilians such as the Nazis
did during the Holocaust and and and
engaging in war actions which you know
are going to inevitably cause death of
civilians so there's an enormous
enormous difference there then he talks
about Amal and Hamas uh I I know the
Bible very well and of course Amal was a
group of people that uh sought to
destroy Israel but when people refer to
Amal they don't refer to the Palestinian
people they refer to Hamas and Hamas is
amalik Hamas is the Nazi party Hamas are
not heroic resistance people they cut
off the breasts of women and throw them
around they behead children they put
children and burn them to death yes they
should be destroyed it's going to be
very difficult this is not going to have
an easy solution Israel May in the end
not be able to completely uh destroy uh
Hamas I hope they can I hope they can in
the way that the United States and
Germany uh destroyed Nazism and
destroyed Imperial Japanese and in the
end what happened is the Japanese and
the Germans were grateful for it and
then the United States and Great Britain
helped rebuild Germany and Japan and
turned them into great allies that's my
hope for Gaza My Hope for Gaza is that
the people of Gaza will finally be rid
of Hamas that uh took over in a bloody
coup and that the United States and
Europe can then rebuild it better than
it was before like a Marshall Plan uh
and hope that a democratically elected
Palestinian people will then have a
two-state solution I've been
in since 1970 let me just jump in there
only tonight the Israeli ambassador to
the UK made it abundantly clear
two-state solution is gone Israel I I'll
play you the clip I'll play you the clip
here yeah but he's wrong is there still
a chance for a two-state solution I
think it's about time for the world to
realize the Oslo Paradigm failed on the
7th of October and we need to build a
new one and in order to build a new one
does that new one include
the Palestinians living in a state of
their own is that what I think the
biggest question is what type of
Palestinians are in the other side this
what Israel
realized the answer is absolutely no you
see when you hear that this confirms
this confirms but hang on Alan this
confirms what many Palestinians have
feared that for 20 years or more uh the
Israeli government and Netanyahu in
particular have had absolutely zero
interest in any two-state solution and
and so if but let's remember that but
let's remember that Israel offered a
two-state solution 1948
1967 1994 2000 2001 they came very close
2001 2005 2007 the vast majority of
Israeli People Israel is a democracy
unlike Hamas the Israeli people will
vote for a two-state solution if the
circumstances are right if there is no
Hamas and if the Palestinian Authority
will have elections and if the people of
West Bank and Gaza vote for I'm going
I'm going to come back will be a two I'm
going to come back to Professor figin in
one second but again today Netanyahu has
said explicitly there can be no Hamas
run or fata run Gaza after this he said
it today
did he's got no intention of either
Hamas or FASA running Gaza so who is's
going to run it I think he thinks he he
he's not going to be in power after this
after this there will be a national
security government probably headed by
people like Gans maybe Bennett uh the
people of Israel are going to decide and
the people of Israel get to make that
decision and they're going to decide on
a two-state solution the one thing
that's clear is with Gaza dominated by
Hamas there cannot be a two State
solution back without Hamas anything's
possible okay I agree with that I don't
think Hamas can possibly be left in
control I just don't think that this
mission is going to eradicate Hamas in
the time scale which America is not
clearly laying down for their support
Professor finlin you may be right how do
you see this playing out from here okay
I would like to say a couple of things
if you don't mind it's okay yeah number
one uh Professor dtz attaches a lot of
uh importance to the what the people of
Israel
want and so let's look at what the
people of Israel want according to the
most recent polls 60% of Israelis
believe Jewish Israelis 60% of Jewish
Israelis believe that Israel is not
using sufficient force in
Gaza 60% believe that Israel should or
the government should escalate the
amount of force it should use in Gaza
number two it's the Israeli government
excuse me it's the Israeli people who
democratically elected this Ultra
right-wing government it's not as if the
claims are made that Hamas has been
imposed on the people of Gaza but
there's no imposition in Israel I quite
agree with professor dtz at least for
Jewish Israelis for Jewish Israelis it's
a democratic country and they
democratically elect Ed the ultra
right-wing government so I think those
are two very good
indications I can say they're very
auspicious indications but they are very
good indications of what the Israeli
people
want number three I'm not now going to
go into a long disquisition on the
history of the so-called peace process
but I would ask your listeners if they
have the time patience and interest to
just Google what's called the peaceful
settlement of the question of Palestine
and that's a general assembly resolution
that comes up every single year for
decades and it calls for that two State
settlement on the June 1967 border and
it calls for a peaceful settlement on
the basis of international law
now if you look at the voting record
every single year it's the whole world
including the state of Palestine on one
side
supporting a two-state settlement on the
basis of international law and on the
other side opposing it's the United
States Israel and usually some South
Pacific atos like
talu Naru and Micronesia and the
Marshall Islands that record is written
in stone it can't be changed and it
makes very clear what is the obstacle to
a settlement the obstacle is Israel
backed by the United States opposes a
two-state settlement on the basis of
inter international law the law that has
been
defined by the international court of
justice the legal arm of the United
Nations now wrong I'm going to make one
remark now which you will find perhaps
controversial or unacceptable peers
however I hope you'll allow me to say it
and then you can engage it as you said
in a civil
fashion you say that the actions of
Hamas have disqualified it from any
participation in a peaceful settlement
now I am not going to make any brief for
Hamas it's for the people of Palestine
to decide who should be their leaders
who should represent them but I do have
to ask you pierce and I respect you so
I'm asking you this as a matter of not
rhetoric but one
intelligent person to another I'm asking
a simple question if it's the case that
the actions of Hamas on October
7th disqualify it from being party to a
peaceful settlement roughly 1,00 people
were killed about 30 of them being
children why is it not then also the
case that the actual of the state of
Israel since October 7th the
deliberate the deliberate war of
genocide against the people of Gaza
which has left about
15,000 people dead not
1,00
15,000 and has left dead not 30 children
but has left Dead about 7,000 children
and as we speak speak now a 7,000 more
children are threatened with death
because of
starvation I ask you as a logical
proposition why isn't the state of
Israel
disqualified from any final settlement
of the question and one last thing
because you ask what do I believe I will
tell you what I believe I believe number
one immediately after the war comes to
an end and the blockade of Gaza that
cruel inhuman blockade of Gaza that war
crime in Gaza that crime against
humanity the blockade of Gaza it has to
be lifted but once there's a ceasefire
and once that inhuman blockade of Gaza
is l lifted once the walls of that
concentration camp come tumbling down
then I see Two Steps step number one
there have to be war crimes prosecutions
I have no problem in saying on both
sides but there must be a
countability you cannot get away with
executing
a war of genocide in broad daylight and
then continue and number two there has
to be a settlement on the basis of
international law that is the only
consensus basis for ending the conflict
once and for all okay I want to just a
very quick reply please Professor D I
was going to end it there but I want to
give you a right of reply on that one
point you're a lawyer uh this point
about international law when President
Biden the head of of America the biggest
strongest Ally for Israel comes out and
says that the bombing has been
indiscriminate he is accusing Israel
directly of committing war crimes that
is a war crime if it has indeed been
indiscriminate is this war now at a
stage where America may pull its support
because they believe that Israel is
breaching international
law it's not uh today 10 is soldiers
including a commander were killed in
Northern Gaza because Israel refused to
bomb that site which it could easily
have done instead it sent in Brave 18 19
20y old some of them considered children
under the Hamas definition of anybody
under 19 and they were all killed
because Israel made a decision not to
bomb indiscriminately it is never bombed
indiscriminately it has always bombed
part of process that it is
because he usually very often use car
carelessly uses words I'm a supporter of
of Joe Biden but he's wrong it's not
indiscriminate it's very very
discriminate in terms of international
law uh uh finklestein is just dead wrong
uh I helped draft 242 the UN resolution
I was working with Arthur Goldberg in
1967 and that talked about territorial
adjustments Israel has the right to make
some territorial adjustments they
shouldn't have had occupation of uh
civilians but going back to the 67
borders is an invitation to suicide and
you know when the blockade of Gaza will
end the day that Hamas is no longer in
control okay and the day when Rockets no
longer attack Israeli civilians that's
the day the blockade will end the
blockade is a good thing designed to
prevent Hamas from firing Rockets using
tunnels and doing a repetition of what
happened on October 7 okay I do I do not
agree that the blockade is a good thing
I do think that the occupation of Gaza
for many decades has been a terrible
thing the plot of the Palestinians has
been horrific none of that justifies
October the 7th which is uh one of the
worst Terror attacks of modern times but
I'm grateful to both of you for agreeing
to come together and having a civilized
uh debate about this we've got to do
more talking this will only get resolved
In The End by people talking and
reaching a resolution so thank you both
of you very much indeed
thank you I appreciate it thank
you